[Musique]
alors comment tu vas je vais bien c'est
juste que je fais ce que je dois faire
et ça veut dire quoi
je m'excuse papa on n'a qu'à des jeunes
et discuter ça on peut le faire par an
s'il te plaît tu es certain que tu as
tout sous contrôle
je sais pourquoi je fais ça mais ça fait
aucune différence toi ça te dérange
parce que là ce que tu as créé de plus
je sais pas de plus personnage la
création en oeuvre enfin tabac ce que je
suis devenu qui es tu devenu unique
c'est moi papa c'est ce que je suis ce
n'est pas toi non je sais que ce n'est
pas toi qu'est ce que tu fais un tu as
toujours voulu tout contrôlé depuis que
je suis né laisse moi laisse moi te
prendre une chambre à part quelques
jeunes après tu vas pas je voulais pas
que ça se passe comme ça
mon fils a disparu nicolas chef s hero2
personnes ont reçu
il y a des moments où je le regarde
cet enfant que j'ai élevé cet enfant que
je croyais parfaitement connaître et
j'ignore qui naît
je croyais qu'on était proche qu'on
était plus qu'un père et son mari ce
pourquoi je me sentais mieux que ça fait
jamais été alors j'ai continué c'est pas
nous ça ça nous ressemble pas
mon fils est quelque part dans la nature
et je ne sais pas ce qu'il fait je ne
sais même pas comment l'aider tard c'est
pas comme si j'étais malade c'est pas un
cancer c'est mon choix et je me suis mis
tout seul là dedans
j'ai joué je ne peux pas y arriver tout
seul
il faut que je trouve un moyen de
combler ce trou noir qui est en moi
j'ai encore une famille
je veux qu'ils soient fiers de moi
[Musique]
ce qui est en toi tu va le retrouver ça
va revenir
tu sais à quel point je t'aime
je t'aime plus que tout plus que tout
plus que tout
[Musique]
m